[Music]  um probably the thing that you're most  likely to have seen would be the office  which was a sitcom on nbc  i could watch any episode of the larry  sanders show i love that show also the  comeback those are shows i go to when i  need just a little pick-me-up but also  some comfort  it does feel like home i really like new  york i've lived here now for oh my gosh  off and on for 20 years and i i love it  here i love the diversity and the  range of stuff to do and the busyness  and it feels very vibrant  you know a quintessential new york  moment is probably what happens  pretty much  every day which is that new yorkers go  about their own business